Mitchell Creek Minh created the show
Clarissa explains it all yeah I did and
some other classics yeah I created Baron
the big blue house and I worked on
Rugrats Ren and Stimpy Doug Rocco but I
loved Clarissa so we came out here to
talk about it and learn some things
about the show that we probably didn't
know cool here we go
[Music]
the latter was I think about four rungs
or something like that it was like about
maybe this high and Sam had a crouched
down underneath the window and go like a
mime you know coming up every time and
he had to slam it on there and we had to
get that guitarist again of course and
when they built the set you could see in
the pilot we eventually fix this right
then the pilot you could see through the
window and see the floor of this dude
yeah i banned purple I would never give
a reason and I kind of rationalize it a
little bit by saying you know I'm trying
to appeal the boys and girls and I said
well it's gotta be all pink and blue you
know we got to use those in our main
colors and purple throws that off
[ __ ] you know I'm complete [ __ ]
right they just ignored me after a while
[Music]
well I can't really tell you is the
problem with that I've never told
anybody even Melissa
I had the most amazing writers I had
Suzanne Collins who wrote Hunger Games
Alexei Young who was one of the main
writers on friends Nina Bieber wrote
plays and wrote Daria I mean these
writers you know all went on to do like
amazing stuff you know if you're like 26
to 36 you know almost universally if I
say I created Clarissa explains it all
they scream like a fourteen-year-old
girl and they say that's my childhood
you made my childhood and those are the
words everybody says it's like my
career's 30 years younger than I am you
know which I love it's super satisfying
it's completely wonderful okay Fred you
ready
I'll take that as a yes
this is Fred Newman hey what do you do
Fred I honk for a living ha I worked on
Nickelodeon show called Doug I did the
sound design and music
dude it's dude it's dude it's dude dude
that wasn't does voice that was actually
my voice dude this dude is just we
wanted to use as much as we could
household objects things that a kid
would have make it sound innocent
because this is a kid's diary I tended
to do a lot of things with my mouth not
only did Fred work on the sounds and
music but was also a voice for a bunch
of the characters porkchop dog he would
actually kind of talk but not quite
Skeeter it's short for mosquito who mad
you know yeah but a little hunk hey Doug
how you doing man I saw here the big
nose
I just thought he would always have this
sort of adenoid thing going on a lot of
post nasal drip bud Dean welcome
newcomer he had big Chiclets pizza and
his name was dink because of double
income no kids the beats
I need more allowance yo lady killer
tofu and that was kind of based on
staying a little bit well Doug maybe
Fred's claim to fame in our eyes he does
all kinds of sounds for movies TV and
radio his first movie was gremlins
I can't even did the bad guy stripe some
of them were cute I did the sound when
the mobile I turn into the bad guys but
Fred's often on screen when you don't
even realize it I did a lot of dogs
movies I will go
you've gotta put real human emotions
coming out of animals or doors the door
has to sound ok let's try a couple horse
[Music]
weasal aliens vibration the message I
say is whatever makes you weird go there
and pursue that mine is sound and never
thought for a second I can do that for a
living but here I am as the Sun sinks
slowly in the West we did you all a fond
farewell
[Music]
in 1992 Nickelodeon debuted the TV show
guts
it was just like American Gladiator only
the contestants were all kids and while
the show was epic in every way the theme
song is one of those pieces where you
start singing it and somebody next to
you joins in so we found the guy who
wrote it my name is Rick McCallum IM the
composer of the nickelodeon theme song
guts do you have it
[Music]
I got the call to do this piece hip hop
was just coming to age immediately it
came to mind do you have it yes they
liked it and they said you think you can
put a little rap to it
yes sure when the Polish guy from West
Virginia I like I can rap yeah it takes
a certain kind of something to keep the
heart pumping something everybody needs
to achieve to succeed you'll need a lot
they were big on the sound effects stuff
and that to it you can hear me in there
I sample my myself so Rick he didn't
just write the theme song for guts he
was kind of the 90's jingle guy for
Nickelodeon guts was my first yeah first
show for Nickelodeon I did some music
for the big help they're all music for
the Kids Choice Awards figure it out a
remake of family double dare I did stuff
for Nick at Nite awesome Nick
oh here's a show I forgot to mention I
did the music for a so called Action
League now now starring my buck of this
how I you know I'd love to be involved
in having a hit record you know I'm
still working on that but I guess you
know to a degree like the guts team
it's my hit so I'm pretty happy about
that
[Music]
[Music]
remember Gullah Gullah island the
nineties kids show on Nick jr. featuring
a fun family and a Polliwog named Bing
abiy well it's a real place kind of I'm
Natalie Dave and I play miss Natalie oh
my god
my name is Rhon days and I served as a
dad
show me how old you are there is no real
place named kala kalah
Island except on TV it is based on the
color geeky culture which was passed on
by enslaved West Africans who were
brought to this country
eg culture was born out of several
African cultures and languages brought
here by enslaved people everything from
cuisines and traditional practices have
been maintained through generations of
settlement in coastal villages in
Georgia and the Carolinas
I am telugu Qi and proud of it it's
important to me to make sure that Gullah
Geechee culture is preserved because
it's a very important factor of American
cultural heritage Natalie and Ron got
the opportunity to present their culture
on TV they jumped at the chance by the
time we met
the woman who became the executive
producer we had been traveling around
the country doing stories and songs of
color culture that's what we did in the
beginning we didn't know that it was so
significant there had never been a show
like that before we wanted a show where
our children could see themselves we
actually ended up with a show where
everybody could see themselves in us
before we go would you guys mind seeing
us out
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you were a kid in the 90s you might
remember this show the Hidden Temple
this guy was the host
Kirk Fogg thank you thank you nice to
see you
legends of the Hidden Temple for those
who didn't watch it was an iconic game
show out of the 90s by Nickelodeon
are you ready Oh Mac let's rock barely
anybody won there were a hundred and
twenty shows and like only 30 winners
teams are you ready I guess now we can
finally get answers to all of our
legends of the Hidden Temple questions
who was Olmec yeah as it turns out there
was a guy standing inside his face but
he stands back there and he has a
microphone here his copy here and he has
his hand on the lever that handles the
mouth I'm gonna ruin it for all the kids
a lot of people asked who were the
temple guards they were the guys who
used to help out during the show but
here's a little behind the scene secret
occasionally some of the writers would
dress up I think they vicariously got a
thrill out of scaring the crap out of
kids going temple I felt bad for a few
of them but they really did scare the
crap out of kids this poor girl got
really super upset in the middle of the
run and she threw up and unfortunately
she threw up in the pit of despair
everybody asked what was the hardest
room and I think probably for everybody
it was the shrine of the silver monkey
these three things look similar together
because they're kind of all silver so
you have to kind of stack them on
I was actually an expert at it so yeah
the temple was pretty impossible is that
the only reason there were so few
winners the producers were only it'll
have to give out eight championships a
year so there was a budget and that's
the truth of that Oh No
[Music]